das ist eine komplett neue erkenntnis
forschende wollen die genaue herkunft
des menschen des homo sapiens gefunden
haben ein australisches forschungsthemen
kommt jetzt mit diesem knaller
es will erdrückende hinweise dafür
aufgespürt haben dass die wiege des
heutigen menschen an einem ganz
bestimmten ort liegt klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonnieren den
kanal und aktiviert die glocken nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
das forschungsteam aus australien ist
sich seiner ergebnisse ganz sicher das
fazit der neuen aufsehenerregenden
studie lautet zusammengenommen denken
mehr dass das südliche afrika der
ursprung der anatomisch modernen
menschen ist die neuen untersuchungen
basieren auf der auswertung von
klimamodellen geografischen daten und
der analyse von 1000 dna proben
untersucht wurde die sogenannte
mitochondriale dna die nur vermutet so
kind weiter gegeben wird so konnte das
forschungsteam die mütterliche erblinie
der heute lebenden menschen weit zurück
kartieren
die rund 1200 proben stammen von
südafrikanern die heutzutage in der
entsprechenden region im südlichen
afrika leben auch mitglieder der
bevölkerungsgruppe häusern nahmen teil
sie gelten als die älteste
menschengruppe überhaupt die frauen und
männer dieser bevölkerungsgruppe
kommunizieren noch heute mit hilfe von
clic lauten demnach nahm alles seinen
anfang vor rund 200.000 jahren an einem
großen see im norden botswanas dieses
gewässer dominierte damals noch diese
region mit dem namen mag gar dicke
guardia kavango die südlich des flusses
sambesi liegt damals also eine oase in
der sonst so ausgedachten afrikanischen
weiter heutzutage befindet sich dort zum
größten teil wüsten der neuen analyse
zufolge soll hier also die geburtsstätte
des modernen menschen die die studie
ermittelt ein gebiet von namibia über
botswana bis nach simbabwe als
heimatregion und würden somit ein ganz
neues licht auf die entwicklung und den
werdegang des homo sapiens dazu waren es
ahs von der university sydney wir wissen
seit langem dass der moderne mensch vor
200.000 jahren in afrika auftauchte aber
bis heute wussten wir nicht wo genau
seine
einmal war 70.000 jahre lang führten
unsere vorfahren wohl in diesem gebiet
magath gar die okawango ein ganz gutes
leben bis sich dann das klima ändert
regen im nordosten und südwesten sorgten
für fruchtbares land und ermöglichte es
unseren vorfahren weitere gebiete zu
erschließen
die neuen ergebnisse werden in der
fachwelt allerdings mit skepsis
aufgenommen die kritik die angewandte
gen-analyse seien nicht in der lage ein
vollständiges bild der
menschheitsgeschichte wiederzugeben
vor allem die größe des kontinents
afrikas macht es den kritikern zufolge
schwierig eine verallgemeinerte aussage
über die genetische herkunft zu treffen
zudem wurde in der studie ja auch nur
ein kleiner teil des menschlichen
erbguts analysiert in seinem interview
mit der britischen zeitung the guardian
sagte experte chris stringer
ich bin definitiv vorsichtig wenn es
darum geht mit modernen genetischen
verteilungen genau festzulegen wo die
ersten populationen vor 200.000 jahren
lebten insbesondere auf einen so großen
und komplexen kontinent wie afrika
ein weiterer kritikpunkt an der schule
ist außerdem dass das australische
forschungsthemen die vielfältige
migration innerhalb afrikas und aus
afrika heraus außer acht gelassen hat
ausgeschlossen werden kann also noch
lange nicht dass wir ein ergebnis des
zusammenschlusses von vorfahren sind die
damals aus verschiedenen regionen
afrikas zueinander fanden weiter
untersuchungen sind also noch notwendig
um weitere beweise zu finden und diesem
rätsel endgültig auf die schliche zu
kommen was kam vor der geschichte der
ursprung der menschheit anklicken
anschauen und kurz gesagt abonnieren
hammer kanal er was soll ich sagen ja
kanal bis dann bleibt dran